it began as just a normal night in
nottingham but what happened to student
sarah changed her life i could have died
that night i was
it was just awful
after becoming seriously unwell and
blacking out sarah spent a night in
hospital she believes she was spiked but
shockingly through an injection i could
just tell something something has
happened because my hand
why is my hand like this and it was
throbbing i think immediately i just
thought
hiv
hepatitis
i just felt physically sick so i was
like that that's really in my system
it's left her and her friends terrified
and uncomfortable about ever going back
out i just feel assaulted
just makes me feel really really sick
and just really angry as well
i don't know what part of someone being
in such a vulnerable state
people look at and think that's funny or
that's attractive
since nightlife reopened there's been a
surge in the number of reported spiking
cases but like zara experienced a new
way of drugging victims through a needle
is causing major concern the fact that i
know i didn't drink much that night
is terrifying because i just can't
fathom into words how
scary it felt to have completely no
memory we take the actions they tell us
to prevent getting a drink spike no one
tells you how to protect yourself from
an injection
we've heard from a number of young women
in scotland manchester cardiff and
liverpool who claim they've been spiked
by injection on a night out police
forces have told us they're
investigating multiple reports
and this is distinctly different to
anything they've seen before
i think it's a fair assumption there may
be a sexual motive in those after today
i will go into those forces and
um i've got rasso or rape leads in each
force to to find out what's going on and
offer any support that we can
it took just a matter of days for this
petition to exceed a hundred thousand
signatures
parliament will now consider stricter
security measures at nightclubs i just
want to go and feel safe and what i
would say to nightclubs is
yes these tougher restrictions may
require
a bit of money they may require more
staffing
but they'll make it safer for us as the
home secretary demands urgent answers
from police forces the night nighttime
industry is calling for an inquiry into
this issue
but all the while this new phenomenon of
targeting young women in clubs
is causing deep discomfort
and concern in zaman rashid sky news